afternoon all and with my good friend
Chris known as chess explained hi Chris
yeah hi welcome to the second timer game
here yes and we've got clock times and
these could be useful and there was
David Bronstein was into clock times to
see positions which might be intense and
how much time someone spent time laughs
that was a very useful isn't it yeah I
think it did matter useful for some
players I I actually never wrote down
clock chimes so but it it might be might
be useful yeah but it also really much
depends on on the player I guess I'm not
I'm not one hundred percent sure
Bronstein was also on yeah person who
got into time travel much I'm not sure
hmm um for my part I never wrote wrote
this down because usually I don't get
into time pressure so it never met it
much to me but it's very interesting to
arm gap to look at the spend time in
relation to the position and CM that
often the remaining time is so yeah more
important than than the actual position
on the mute or at least plays a huge
role because you simply cannot do some
things with very little time well
ideally I think in the most critical
positions where there's an opportunity
to gain the decisive advantage you'd
hope that the player allocate small time
to the critical positions rather than
routine positions yeah this is this is
certainly true but it's Nevel chess is a
complex game sometimes even in the in
the critical position sometimes you just
have this strong hunch that this move
might just be the correct one and then
you just play it but this is also useful
to know so it's basically may be a good
thing to to do this yeah to do this
protocol of your of your own time and
the opponent's time but yeah I think if
you if you used to it then it's ok well
I never did it
so no no experience with this so okay
let's see how the game progressed okay
so a nine kicked off with e four and
then we saw Sicilian defense from
girlfriend and repeat of the Sicilian
sveshnikov invitation which is again
rejected with the anti symmetric or
Bishop b5 all it's very popular move now
Bishop b5 in its own right rather than
d4 so has anand got something up his
sleeve so after e6 we saw Bishop takes
c6 immediately again too dense black
spawn structure with a double porns yeah
without night g---seven so now be free
again yeah and this is a repeat of one
of the match games on in which
girlfriend played five yes and eat oh
yeah I remember when we did this video
that that I said maybe the c5 move would
would be three out of business or
something but okay here obviously the
the UH non team came up with some new
idea and I think we will see this idea
soon in the game yes it's quite amazing
it is like a continuation of the match
discussion a theoretical debate has been
continued here yeah so Knight takes e4
27 and now the innovation I think was
here the innovative move coming up d 4
yeah right in the match a match game I'm
not quite sure of the number he played
good night to see for which is also yeah
pretty logical and also the kind of move
you might want to play if you you're not
prepared for this right before just safe
move but I think b4 is very hard to you
had to work out at the board if you look
at the complications that come up now
but oh this looks funny right okay night
before so yeah um so instead of default
there was 94 and in that previous game
and then we saw an an equalization
didn't we
after night so yeah it was pretty much
nothing after a couple of moves but now
it gets quite sharp immediately black
plays d6 and I think this is more or
less the only move which makes sense
here and then we go Queenie form and now
Queenie too so I'm just going to go back
to cancer this position so I registers
Saudi for cod6 was played and now Knight
takes c6 sorry if C takes d4 would that
be any good if C takes d4 being played
there yeah I think and just take the
fall with the Queen and the Queen yeah
I'm not sure that there should be
anything here so I cannot play d 6 you
can just kept on c6 now and can no move
really the Queen only seven is quite
silly after all if it doesn't win when
the porn on the forum this is silly this
is not good as it just may be C free
here ya can also exchange Bishop t2 and
I porn up c3 also am I just watched
establish these two pawns in the sensor
that'll be quite good maybe yeah yeah
this is just extra extra material for
white so I'm amateur but it looks pretty
much forced what happens now 3696
Queenie form check s'ok we need to
pinning that otherwise you can lose the
night so um check exchange your Queens
mmm interesting though exchange the
Queen's Own so who's doing better here
do you think well yeah I think the only
way to find this artist to to invest
like half an hour and do some do some
analysis because this is a purely
technical positional it's very very
opened up and um yeah why does the pawn
up yeah you always need to take this
into account and black needs to do
something to to get it back yeah
and well it's um it's very very quick
now so Bishop e7 yeah I think yeah and
then and then interesting but this is of
course part of the preparation here and
also quite amazing because some Agathon
was playing quickly up to this point but
you sank into deep thought pretty
quickly and also I mean I most bit
surprised because this should be part of
the preparation really what happens now
yeah here white has an alternative hung
in place 95 which is the the sharpest
move obviously because it gives you two
hanging and seeing from the clock time
see let's solve this out why could have
played d5 also the five years yeah also
I'm the move to look at well this is not
really playing for for a big advantage
but it would be a very safe choice also
like it spawned back pretty easily
wouldn't you get the D fire are you
going to take on c6 so I'm thinking
Knight c3 95 could be useful yeah I
think just kinky 7i think alright so
basically that really forces White's
just so this this c4 say would ya it see
for sure take your time slight see free
yeah and then on I need to maybe rook e8
first all right now because it seems
actually Bishop g5 might be useful also
check check yeah just again this a
little bit of time here and then I'd f6
ended so it's very it looks very equal
this position wondering about this d 5
square Bishop g5 there's a problem d 50
and I'm not with the King on c6 like and
paper should be seven here or just 94
maybe 94 seediest right it's it's a
position you can never win with black
but it's also very difficult to lose it
you know it's just a dressing up not
they're not enough pieces left to to
create anything this kind of wholeness
would be a problem on d5 before white
would get a night there against the
bishop but you don't manage this so this
is this would be a nice position for for
a game which white all accounts doesn't
want to lose but well this was not the
point they obviously did some very
concrete preparation with 9 a-5 yes and
to be honest a couple of moves later I
were thinking yeah but she is winning
this game out of his preparation but it
didn't happen mmm okay so now he took on
g2 not worried about this geofoam
pressure yeah it's the only move what
can you do otherwise you're just you
just lost basically yeah look g1 and now
I'm yeah I think he he started to invest
time now um to h3 right oh yeah so 23
minutes here 50 freighter so how long
did he spend on that move roughly so
he's been about two minutes on one move
here yeah and this is a kind of thing if
you have if you look at this I'm not
sure I don't want to want to question
every year every move in terms of time
spent here but where else would you go
yeah Bishop evil yeah that was that was
something in the longines which svidler
was going on about cutting down the
amount of analysis if waiting for the
opponent play one out of the three Robin
I mean how else would you go if you go
to you 45 you get hit with 93 put
another porn sack yeah I think it's just
logical taking all this also and now
white would Leno take on c5 of you
should f4 or whatever it's like white
has developed everything and like
nothing how no [ __ ] before CD though
don't you want to get 95 I'm not
calculating you all right just just
general principle you have got
everything out here 95 maybe also oh
this is very very dangerous yeah yeah
you've got all pieces attacking you and
you cannot you cannot play this anyway I
think so much in check you got rookie
one you
97 this this will be brilliant these
nights yeah this this is just really
dangerous the other work could be used
comes Eve Eve oh yeah so I think it adds
up if you use to two minutes here maybe
your call sir could have come up with
the decision of bishop age 30 after one
minute I think this is one difference
maybe between Sharon announcement
between shijia and and galfond I think
given this position I think Alan would
have made this move ready in one minute
and not into and this adds up somehow
yeah okay so Bishop h3 and okay so now
we see details see 5 which makes way
maybe for this bishop on this diagonal
potentially yeah it's changing the pawn
structure quite significantly as well
but why doesn't want to look after the
d4 pawn maybe yeah this makes this makes
lots of sense to to get everything
active here so you see that why does
intending to play Knights to d5 or
b-five yes I remember this looking
really dangerous Oh in fact John
Spillman was one of the commentators on
the ICC looking very optimistically as
Oh black needed to sacrifice um a pawn
to get some play so yeah yeah I thought
I thought wide was just winning out of
the opening just just and also
considering that it was all prepared at
home so to say yeah um but okay
girlfriend I think did a brilliant
defense in this game yes absolutely that
he that he didn't didn't go down to this
was so really remarkable yeah um okay so
long castle soon and now look at look at
the time 17 minutes 17 yeah I just
thought yeah he's one of those
perfectionist you you know I have I my
good friend alex is also perfectionist
and you know I hope he doesn't mind me
saying you know he did brilliantly in
the hearts League which is more with the
Germans and much longer time limits then
the middle term middlesex league which I
did better and I did worse than the
Hartley so if your perfectionist that
fundamentally effects you know sometimes
how well you do on different time limits
and being a perfection
then rapid even with ten second it ten
second increment isn't that much so you
can't really be a perfectionist and
rapid you end up blundering later yeah
it's of course its side it was a
difficult a difficult position to to
play mm-hmm but I think he invested like
six minutes or something on long castles
and yeah it's sort of it's sort of adds
up but but you what what also what you
what you need it here that that you some
are really managed to get get a game
here and yeah with black and this is
difficult enough considering that it
looks very dangerous yeah okay mom so
it's our porn-star counts porn sack of
g7 to get his bit cell might be fine was
looking like a menace if he doesn't play
Bishop these things though he's going to
get destroyed off the night be five what
else does he play if he try if he takes
time to try and take this porn before
moving the bishop then night d 5 there's
no defense here is there you know this
is I think that gets just toes chair and
there's also rook g-free potentially
Roxy free if needed get sample on this
bishop and you don't have a mafia really
to to prevent hide a 71 this kind of
stuff yeah so you say this is an example
check the King would be just ping rolled
over here yeah yeah this is so should be
juicy yeah very nice yeah this is just
just not playable hmm since uh maybe you
have some water on the chest maybe you
can play Knight f6 or something but well
he invested in another seven minutes 22
when Bishop t 60 0 di just fought yeah
the writing was on the walls like the
business ten minutes 59 years he's like
he's playing basically a time odds game
now yeah it's like split yeah no mods
isn't it against the errand and the
position is it's already it's also still
bad here so it's a really remarkable
that you fought for turn himself back
into this game so I think why took now I
played rock
she five which looks very strong yeah
rusty fun instead of root g 7 so let's
see rook g700 chief ray brook g7 what
would let do yeah maybe just night night
night night development to I to f6 or
maybe Haven h6 so offering another pawn
and I think this was mentioned by John
Spillman actually night h6 the f5 to d4
as a plant yeah this square here yeah
this also just keeps f7 protected from
normal dead you have got rook e8 coming
up on so yeah this is maybe the betans
hmm and that's xf7 years so we're going
to get a tempo gain so that's probably
why rook takes g7 was rejected in fact
if we look at in this position there's
no way white can get an advantage then
here he doubles up rooks and plays root
GA or no because also the Kings in fire
with rook e8 the White King yeah its
King as a source of counter play here
for black and this is just the g7 point
is pretty much not important in this
position but if you get c5 you've got
three two one on the on the queenside
end lots of end games are just winning
three to one so I'm getting c5 is just
much more important than your not
capturing a pawn on its initial square
here in fact this is just to show the
mask you which one could be facing an
example check and then this gets really
really nasty young rogue f6 is checkmate
that's quicker than I expected okay so
so forget rook takes g7 in case anyone
was wondering Brooke g3 is putting this
might as well go for the see five
minutes near the king any way to get to
get the King attack suits a rookie five
powerful move so he's got nearly double
the amount of time well nearly double
yeah you spend a couple of minutes here
and so is this most likely out of
preparation no but it's also yeah the
great result here
now I was really surprised that ride was
not winning pretty much instantly here
so nice it's offering c5 which teaches
taken so white now is again a porn up
here and he has a free to one poor
majority here but the king is is not
that safe on e2 ok so the King goes to
be eight and then we see knight c 4 y
and then that maybe wasn't doing so much
any more than a five so he wants it back
i think most likely to e3 to mmm help
his King and defending so I'm necessary
also very logical move yeah so he's
attacking the rook at the moment um as
well so this place a check is played so
Knightly free now Knight g4 putting a
lot of pressure all of a sudden well a
little bit on on f2 and III maybe even
rook have six to attack f2 later we'll
just doubling to attack evening yeah
it's also it looks a bit crazy but also
h2 is hanging yes I used to for Bishop
g4 might be useful yeah it's not on it's
just helping to set up more play on the
King so white needs to react to this in
a way and it's not not so easy actually
hmm I actually forgot what he played
daddy 595 yeah yeah so okay 95 he's
supporting III bit more with this move
and maybe wants to play also see for at
some point or just rook now the brook is
tied down to d5 now because this nasty
pin on III yeah what general what you
need to consider about this position um
somehow you you would expect wide to be
better young because he he wasn't in
preparation
not all his moves he saw the extra corn
and so on yeah but it'sit's not easy at
all to to convert this because right
right now odd next pieces I active yeah
they're very logical placed these rugs
yeah the rooks are on the settings of
central France I'm pressurizing White's
King the night on g4 is doing some some
work on III on h2 and this Bishop own
age three ok this would see later can be
deployed nicely and if you if you look
at it just sometimes I try to assess
positions if I just what extra material
yard I just imagine the extreme material
would not be there how would I assess
this position so if I would just well k
it's here it's not so easy to to take a
pawn away but let's say white would
wouldn't have to see to pawn yeah yeah
just imagine this then black would be
simply very much better black would be
better for wild bags you could double up
ropes on c5 the c2 is not that they
wreck see one yeah it just do it yeah
okay maybe maybe this is a problem you
cannot really take upon aware here which
aren't any concrete yeah player leather
table I wanted to take away the a porn
but this would make a seven very weak
but ok that's not it's it's a yam this
looks a problem it's stranded in the
opponent's territory and a bit silly
there on c5 in a way leisure this is the
only active piecewise does really this
can his doings doing some work also
protecting d5 and and the labeling and
checked on b5 and so on and what I'm
saying is at the moment the extra policy
a porn or the C porn and this pawn is
not doing anything at the moment it's
not an active unit in the battle so to
say so if white can sort of yeah calm
down this position and get into some
sort of real endgame yeah we're we're
black doesn't have any concrete play
then okay then it might be even a
winning advantage but at the moment it's
just an open technical fight for
for concrete things like White's King
position and so on so it's not like okay
I've got an extra point and winning
easily yeah it's not like that at all
but also if you look both whites nights
are under immense pressure because also
Bishop g2 might be on the cards to hit
the five it's not at all easy yeah and
II freeze on the pressure so yeah this
is very very tricky unpleasant i would
say so what does she do here so it off
tonight takes III that simplifies a bit
maybe that helps white a little bit it
would seem to take some of the pressure
away this night take see free yeah but
it's got a very nice idea I was very
impressed with this actually and now
you're fine yeah guesses oh yes everyone
was saying this was really high class
what he did here this check followed by
what the next boat beautiful I wonder if
our YouTube viewers can guess what
happened here after every guest the move
will let you guys on YouTube guess the
move if we give you 10 seconds what does
black play here so he's basically he is
in crew increase the danger of this this
pin has knee against the night it's not
supported by the porn anymore yeah this
this is very important and he plays in
our brilliant move he plays Bishop c8
which opens up new avenue of attack on
this diagonal yeah and also be seven
young well see force a move that white
can always play to to stop this bishop
from being active them but on b7 you
would also attack f3 so f3 as a point of
a technology yes yeah and one idea of
this whole procedure was also to allow a
rope to hh-60 to connect h2 immense all
these possibilities these rooks are
really working well with this bishop
here this night seems a real liability
in many variations on e3 and these porn
Z are isolated aren't they blacks got
the more compact structure these pawns
are targets so it's still very dangerous
uniform and then close to you know
getting wiped out here in a way
all done yeah the funny thing is I just
turned on an engine briefly and it gives
this position s completely gray would
the fellow feel enough it gave white
some advantage before but somehow there
must have been some inaccurate move by
right but but it's not obvious what you
should have done what he did wrong but
engines will find the one in 20 moves
which will keep the decision a cool but
humans in time pressure it's going to be
well and that hasn't gotten time
pressure though he's got 14 about 14
minutes here 55 according to this yeah
I'd also the five minutes for black
outsourcer rather rather okay yeah but
ok let's let's see what Howard how it
continues so rookie one yeah rook e1 and
our work ethics I guess to a tech h2 yes
now if we look at how on the alternative
bishop I six here check is that that's
not dangerous here I suppose see full
would be sufficient would it yeah but
you could also see form might be okay
the girls begin g6 with King f2 now good
cookie one yeah but you can also
consider moving the King immediately but
it's not it's not clear that the bishop
is doing so much on a six the point of
the spear should see it was more to go
to be seven I think right you can play
king f2 actually you could think of it
rock d to check king g3 it's not clear
that you've got anything concreting I
see because the noise potato things will
be got enough protection and the King's
actually protecting it looks it looks a
bit shaky but I'm not sure that this is
a problem for white uh-huh this new you
see the c-4 move also opens up the
second-ranked completely for the rock
enter its I think see for some more
human move certainly to to play but I
think rook h6 is just just so natural
you you really ask yourself what what is
why playing now really rook age one yeah
let's good point this poor isolated pool
over here being victimized and the Kings
far away from it come get ya and the
danger here is if white wood
the spawn yeah he would be instantly
close to lost I guess he was like will
keep all his activity and he's got the
the ship coming to be seven which is
just stronger than the night you know
and the age porn is running and so on
yeah and white is somewhat slow with his
pawns so he really doesn't have much
choice here he needs to keep his his
bits together here but form 1120 night
here full minute 28 so rook h1 and then
rook v6 yeah okay okay rookie six but
what what Gavin could have played also
just rock d6 back rook d6 yeah yeah with
the idea of playing rook to the edge
ready to 12 or 14 1 cent what is why
playing now well now there is the threat
of Bishop I six isn't there yeah because
that fret is now renewed here if the
rooks not on a one then this is a big
problem this every night I just just to
demonstrate that just with the token
move yeah okay something like a for
something yeah English the night's lost
here with a rookie on anyone you can't
play king f2 it's a nightmare yeah this
is just over so I think wide maybe needs
to play rook e1 yeah so what so it was a
very very tough decision yet but the
girlfriends actually playing for one
year now it could have played rugby six
I think it was perfectly aware that this
petraw hmm yeah and he was in I don't
know if I have four minutes for a
against 11 wouldn't you be happy
withdrawal and trunk line witness all it
depends yeah but ok this is a
disposition is just just nice yeah hmm
it's a it's not like he's lacking in
fighting spirit so he wanted to try here
and once you need to see okay you like
the position you fought yourself out of
this bad position in the opening and I
think Alan wasn't feeling too happy yeah
it was pretty sure about this and just
imagine
you play on and windows as black this
would be huge in the in terms of of the
match because then girlfriend let's just
imagine you would have been up one and a
half a half after two games you're
pretty much sure to at least reach the
blitz games because you wouldn't
wouldn't lose two games yeah so so
rookie one virtually forced here in your
opinion rookie one is virtually every
ones to what Canyon what else can you
play this noise just a liability because
if you try and wriggle out then there's
route detours and check yeah and you can
play king you 1 here I checking the rook
and then you just maybe drop back Rock
26 and King f2 and is also draw you know
this is another possible draw mm-hmm so
yeah rook thesis okay so he's playing
for a win with rook e6 if we revert back
to the game continuation rookie six and
now this gives the chance for Roxy free
f5 yeah looks very dangerous at five
which it isn't Addison attractive
possibility yeah yes I think it's
understandable that he wanted to try
it's a bit risky with the time but as he
said in the press conference this was
his sir this is his usual time
management in a rapid game so um well he
came to this point with this time in it
yes he greased joke one of the top
Russian players in the world didn't he
in Indian qualifier no that was in the
long game this was la games yeah sorry
bill does the very last long game wasn't
it before type before brad.leah exactly
they played a couple of drawers and
Geffen won the last game yeah but yeah
okay if you if you play with this time
management all your life it's you should
continue doing so in this crucial match
circulate them and you're not playing on
and all day it was always so quick in
the rapid games sir King king day to if
F for that will be asking for trouble on
this diagonal unit Bishop b7 yeah it's
also maybe and yeah but but what what do
you play and rookie falls so rookie fool
let's say rook everyone yeah to protect
their efficiency six yeah oh yeah this
is very beautiful coordination of the
rugs oh man oh this is just painful
isn't it yeah so it it hasn't really had
a point to play on it so especially if
you consider it's not not a point of
maybe the computer will tell you that
why disappoint happens can somehow can
consolidate this but it's just very
uncomfortable to play for white you know
it's need to you need to make those
somewhat ugly defensive moves so Detroit
King so I guess this gets destroyed with
just F for here yeah the brook
infiltration to e2 I don't be don't be
crushing here yes checkmate also a
bishop HH freaky issues mating the SW
that wouldn't be too good yeah checkmate
okay so not too many choices in this
position of the FI yeah i think maybe
can you twist the only more only move as
informative would say a box symbol so
King d2 and now f4 so this infiltration
is invited to e to potentially so night
d 5 but g5 protecting the porn not not
rushing for rook any Brooke move or
anything just g5 but this pawn chain
reminds me of the Kings gambit if it can
be undermined f4 will be weak and so if
why it's got the undermining move a
chore that's potentially dangerous to
try and shatter this pawn chain yeah
sure but if you're if you're in the
process loose f3 you lost satellite yeah
hmm so it's it's sharp he just wanted to
he did offer it here with luck with
little time on the clock so very brave
play um and and like a sir I'm not sure
I didn't analyze it here I was long but
I can can't imagine that black should be
worse here
just a question if white can hold or
whatever I think you must have misplayed
it somehow in the coming in the coming
moves but ok but let's see what happens
the rookie free was blind yeah this rock
on c3 was really a bit funny here you
were thinking what's the one to have C 4
plus the possibility to to secure this
night here if it gets a tech but there
should be seven mm-hmm okay like it's
very active them so check King see one
rook f2 so he is potentially targeting
you know that as well like this
potentially or just maybe maybe even G
floor something oh no no rockbrook HOA
it both rooks on the second rank of
course of course get both rooks on the
second rank and c 2 and h 2 will be on
the fire yo it's very dangerous so what
was played here each fall yeah he wanted
to activators his rookie year on the
edge from undermined the pawn chain yeah
and now it's better think of precise
calculation which is of course difficult
here with the realities of there's a
little time you know I don't remember
what you played actually rook e to so it
accepts the invitation to attack c2 but
there's no H to target after Rachel and
this pawn chains about to be on the mind
so rook see free protecting c2 but also
cutting the King off a bit which might
be tactically useful later Brooksie free
I want to point out earn a move before
if you if you take the the rock move
back here yeah um black could also play
here there should be seven yeah um it's
a bit different there should be some
that say edge takes g5 and then look to
you two yeah I could make the move my
survey I keep forgetting that I could
could enter them myself song that's okay
let me control if you want undermine so
rookie to ya know now how do you protect
c2
this is a difference to the gambia in
the game who had the the rook on c3 and
then white could actually quite quite
could protect c2 with his rook but he
cannot play rock c3 now because the
night is lost so how do you protect it I
don't what about if I just play rotates
h7 because I've got rock AJ to look
forward to here now yeah and then Roxy
to check in d1 yeah Andrew ketchum
business dangerous for the black king no
um yeah it's dangerous for both Kings
most likely be a draw I'm not sure I
didn't calculate so much here but black
is threatening made also so yeah it
might be a draw rogue HH you should see
it link King move somewhere but then
again move kinking you want yeah maybe
can you one here and this is the drama
likely mmm yeah if one gets an extra
move in the rootsy free might be
dangerous will not eat seven yeah this
is most likely a draw yeah I mean rook
rook a to YouTube checking you one work
8 a-2 is a draw here I mean this is this
kind of woods I didn't want to want to
draw an arrow I wanted to move the piece
so this this this kind of stuff is to
draw immediately hmm so it's very
difficult very difficult yeah so maybe
this this was was better but because it
may be the exact move adubato k 3 330 on
the clock very difficult yeah it's about
it's a draw yeah not like that could
could win here okay so he played the
ragi to immediately which is also very
natural move so Roxy fritz hansen and
now Bishop d7 so f freeze on on the line
here if the low moves and then black
spawns could be looking more dangerous
so rook d1 just holding the 4g takes h4
but he smashed his own porn chain but
he's that paul is also potentially
dangerous but these pawns are a week now
are potentially is isolated free
hornsey yeah it gets we've got lots of
exchanges coming up now so no tanks are
full the brook moves it was it was
attacked there um yeah I think it's it's
own it's clear know that the worst is
over for white so somehow black black
the tick activity year yam didn't really
am yeah wasn't really enough to to give
me TM give give some some immediate
rewards what black and can hope for is
to exchange let's say h4 with against f3
and then getting town to play with the
age corn coming down the board mmm and
you've got the bishop which is yeah
helpful all those sir free porns yes um
something went wrong a bit maybe this
Bishop d7 would have been better to to
secure the straw but it's difficult of
course now also you would need to look
at the clock seared graph on down 55
seconds ridiculous so I'm just feeling
us ridiculous yeah i mean he's such a
perfectionist though to his credit and
it worked for him to get to this point
but i don't know about this you know 55
i know it tends to having good it was it
was a difficult difficult position and
it also it looks it looks hello because
our nerd is so quick mmm let's say i
think it's also quite ridiculous that
he's got eight minutes left yeah if you
look at may be ridiculous is unfair word
but look it was a super complicated
position yeah and i'm pretty sure lots
of players would be down to let's say
two or three minutes is why they might
have some time tammy extra complaint
compared to the 55 seconds black ass but
he's played this so quickly and it was
very difficult for right to play so i
think he did very well in keeping all
this together after um it's somehow when
went wrong after the opening i think we
agree that in the opening word was very
good maybe close to two winning somehow
but then the game somewhat shifted in
lex and legs favor and you did a good
job and keeping all this together here
he really maximized these rooks and
Bishop earlier on for a bit they look
here dangerous and the night on III was
looking fragile the night's not looking
that fragile now no white s-sir has
really consolidated now and of course
the sir this trade now I'm Jackie a
leads to the men dead game yeah so okay
so now and then is actually two pawns up
in this moment but with every and see to
one of those about to be picked off okay
so in this position we've see to an f3
on the fire and then chooses just rook
h5 interesting move rook h5 gathers was
so interesting tactical move and I think
it took on c2 an alright so Bishop takes
see two check check and I of course the
King moves that rook c5 winning a piece
yeah so needs to get to aid and there
looks to be a nasty night d 5 season I
think a six or something like that so
Knightly five threatens 97 mate okay
yeah it's always nice okay so a 6 gives
the king at a seven but now brooke a 5
which not only attacks but potentially
defends a two ok the bishops tied down
to the Kings actually attacking the
bishop zone yeah white wants to get
connected past points here this was I
think the whole point of this procedure
getting the a6 porn mmm it looks as
though yeah so night before will be
potentially forking at least two and he
played that so night before which it
moves so it's going to get he's got the
two connected passports as you saw
rook takes a free but blacks got
potentially a runner potentially yeah
but yeah I think this position is so
very dry hmm so the age corn is so it's
just quick yeah and we've got this funny
ruling chess that one ha spawn is always
quicker than two haha who said that I'm
not sure it's rule it's a row I thought
you happily you telling me off about
rules on chesky cafe all the time and
then you're saying this funny rule I've
never heard of me yeah but it's true
what you mean is true do you mean it
depends on the position surely no no no
no no just mathematically one point is
quicker oh no no no really it's just it
takes five moves to promote this in the
H porn but promoting a and B took stakes
lot lots of more moves that's only
because in this position eighth or b4 b5
a5 just like ten moves well it's kiss
these pieces are in Hawaii and the
kingdom it okay no why here look there's
a free run on the motorway here yeah
yeah you got these you got congestion
charges on this side of the board yeah
yeah also also black has got got the
bishop iam 22 to support his pawn the
bishop also controls h1 so this is a
potentially very dangerous age porn yeah
and it's not easy to see how white would
get his pawn so going quickly now so um
yeah he just fought on really a
admirably but he's down to 18 seconds
here seaforth yeah I remember British am
shaking Adams had this this rice of
passports and Maxie he's always winning
those races he makes sure his passport
look quicker that's a very good skill so
if you've heard this has got passport
you got very very helpful so Brooke have
for a free black man they are they are
plotting along it seems not even going
with full a4 move just having to defend
before
so rook g4 now the King moves you know
h5 so is it really that dangerous yeah
and now we see that the icy times are a
bit bit weird here oh yeah this is Miss
minus beta bed but by this point he was
down to basically nothing and was
playing on increment only here and
somehow it also didn't manage to to make
let's say three or four moves quickly in
a row to UM get to to get a little bit
of a backup time for later so okay the
problem is the bishop is it's a nice
piece yeah but the lower of the time the
more dangerous the night gets the old
blitz you the old blitz phenomena that
don't Sami blitz rule now you don't say
that's the rule I know about the nights
are tricky i know in place yeah yeah but
this is this is just this is just the
problem we all know from quick turn
control games that those Forks are
dangerous yeah check so check and there
is a folk um check okay Bishop eateth
the bishop getting out of the way for a
moment the night is being tricky and now
okay can the porn progress here it plays
H horse only free steps away yes here it
is quicker White has anticipated so
rookie five okay the rooks gonna
heroically win the bishop and go back
there's no time to to rush that upon the
bishop has to move okay now there's a
fret also potentially a rookie free as
well so night f4 though check check the
Kings actually making progress the king
is getting quite good here now yeah on
d4 and now you see the the combined
forces he off the rock and Bishop yeah
I'm really a maid gave right no choice
than to to give up the a porn if you
would have let say player okay 52 to
protect his pawn on on a three
then yeah that's just each day just h3 I
usually what about this rook is rookie
with age very strongly stage for a
strong run I'm not sure maybe a rock
edge fire but maybe you can play rook f3
year rook f3 first instead of H for this
little beige free um so like you keep
pressing this this wrong button here
oops yeah maybe maybe this one here I'll
look half of rear and then yeah well
what does why do now if you play
something like see ya then the root
cannot go to age five hundred years
right is no page one and most likely the
H porn white glare to second slide yet
so I think maybe why didn't have much
choice here you needed to do to give the
a porn for the H porn yeah and it's this
basically from a position point of view
this concedes the draw yeah but ok at
the time and now every da was back on 40
seconds here amazing amazing amazing and
then he and ok but the nights are super
tricky this is just the problem here yes
but i think i Doan said um later on um
he likes his night and work on the
Sabbath causing potential you know
problems of course it's not it's not
super easy ok if you play a long time
game and would have like 20 minutes here
I think it would have would have easily
drawn this but at this time it's just
it's just very tricky so night d 5 so
wrote g5 be five so it's looking like
our torture position a little bit but
Bishop f5 ok and I think one of the
commentators indicated soon that the get
a bishop on b7 would be easily drawing
blockading the porn if that could be
arranged maybe yeah but something
horrible was falling into soon let's
just okay so Bishop f3
Jack Illinois one's gonna have to move
and one thing about the ICC at times he
had decided to say because all the times
are roughly okay during the game but at
this point he was down to zero right leg
was really down to zero and just playing
each move he spent like eight seconds
for each move and was moving with two
seconds left on the clock yeah so um and
this is the problem if you would really
would have had 50 seconds I think he
maybe would have drawn this right but
for instance just to take this back just
just for a second here Bishop e2 bit no
sorry Bishop e2 you can't play wish me
to watch why kinda oh because brooke and
night i was that drawn yeah that's gonna
be drawn yeah i think it would be glad
to get this i mean he would have it
would continue but you don't have to
it's easier to to to hold i think than
the position before i think this is one
one thing but okay it's not not an idea
to the problem but why dwight could
write could go i'd be 66 also yeah and
then it continues let's say yeah look
check here I was King King leader isn't
kini freed understand yeah the ideas the
ideas um just win that cornea okay you
just trying to win that pool yet to get
the roofing light versus rock so I
gather I want to get get this here here
so these kind of tricks but you have you
ain't got eight seconds on the clock and
this pressure it's difficult okay I
think what about you played didn't
didn't lose or something but um
throwback to the Galen okay we'll go get
to the game position so Bishop d7 and it
looks as though you know okay how's
white gonna make progress so is he going
to reverberate the Bishop Bishop d5 the
Knights coming to see five though a dot
square away from the bishop and it looks
you know that's us that's nitinol t
isn't it that night on c5 yeah once he
got his position
pretty sure that black would lose this
because it's just it just so annoying to
play with words the seconds on the clock
you've got all those they've got the
night Forks you get potential made ideas
yes i'm not sure i didn't didn't analyze
this and if it's still a draw I'm not
sure mmm not sure really so King c7 rock
g6 and that wrote g6 contains a nasty
thing about it these guys are about to
be [ __ ] after King da are I think we
get the mighty folk now is it this
position oh no not I was just wondering
about check and night g5 button check
and night g5 or is it another fork now
there's also check and Knight d4 check
now night before yeah this is what
happened and it's the position of the
King in relation to the pool which makes
this this this real component in winning
isn't it that's um yeah this is winning
now and he immediately resigned the guy
takes f3 king be 6 and this is over it's
over here he resigned him but sorry
though this move and now we did say
check check and rook b8 was the signal
of the end so can you explain so route
b8 why is that such powerful move it's
because the King can now move to a 7 is
it and then be six is it because it's
supporting b5 here isn't it from be 81
what is rugby ate the most accurate our
winning movies technique is net for
grandmasters but i'm not sure if maybe
I'd learn what's a winning also this
looks very clean though but but the idea
is to protect the porn so that King a7
and b6 isn't it yeah in general you're
right but I'm not sure maybe Adam also
winning also well let's let's give an
example though so here black resins but
this a king d6 king yeah a 70 know
also you kicked the King back here sorry
drivel that be trivial yeah and can just
drop the rook back now exactly and then
you can just advance upon you've got
those and I'm not sure in Germany it is
building a bridge building bridges then
the only check you dance with so if we
just followed this through just just
just for people just just to know you
get this critical position where um you
can come back on you now check out your
bridge here check and there's no time
for the black king yeah this is a draw
oh good have I miss played it yeah you
need you must be seven first yet Sorry
Sorry Sorry so now you can just go it's
white murah you can just just play a
kicking here and then be seven and then
the whole procedure need to go to be
seven recesses first ok and now now it's
over and now I'm sorry that's quite
critical good good revision here but now
you the gang pops out eventually to to
get to check this bridge point here
check and now this the King cannot do
Superman to stop the porn sorry about
that it's good to brush off one piece
rings hey I didn't see but just just to
show in this concrete position now here
I'm you played this this year you can
you can also play this year this also
winning and then King a seven and be
eight wins also so this is the main
thing is that the king is cut off here
yeah the King Kong can't rescue
situation here can use everything I
seven this is the problem is there's
nothing somehow I'm doing this wrong so
don't know I moved that sorry I can I
cannot move her narrow draw an error
because okay I did I did something wrong
here the main point here is that the
ruckus is cutting off the King here yeah
and likes king is is not able to assist
here you know and um yeah very unlucky
finish of this of this game but ok it's
not a matter of luck it's metal from
yeah spending your time
but I think the commentators was saying
about this Bishop d7 if that night Falk
hadn't occurred let's just quickly just
rewind just a little bit here so he
allows that critical nightfall track
which is unfortunate now I think if
you're just done Bishop put the bishop
out of the way is it black to move here
black moved rook f5 so okay if he's got
loads of time keeps the bishop out of
the way of any night fork prevented it I
think I don't know the position looks
already very tricky hmm of course is
better yeah but you'd end up with your
rook night versus rook situation if the
bishop could even sacrifice itself yeah
most likely you would you would end well
I blew this and that's that's you say
that that's a few reticle draw isn't
that rook and like buses right but in
practice there's winning chances yeah
but they're very slight I think as far
off once wanted famously against poor
Garbutt and it is one once in a while a
few of your very low on time I think
Alan would have played on most likely
but um yeah well playing on rook at
night where this rook is some hmm it's
not unfair should play this on time but
I think it's very manageable to defend
it as black if you got a little bit of
time on the clock so in the worst case
scenario he could have just made sure
his Bishop wasn't going to be fooled I
just try and sack for the porn in the
worst-case scenario yeah i think i think
what Gavin what a nerd would have done
is to avoid this scenario and just try
and trying to sort of circle around with
his pieces and always keep those those
folk ideas intact hmm um I think it
could have gone on forever at least for
a couple of more moves but okay what can
you do a huge fight in this game so
quick overview in summary shall we yeah
okay so Sicilian um Suresh Nick off with
a novelty uncooked probably from the
main match Saudi for
which I think people think this would be
very unpleasant shelf and cope with Jack
so but he coped admirably creating huge
count by with a counter Paul sacrifice
here idea Bishop d6 g7 is pointless to
get because of this night h6 to f5 to d4
but instead this seemingly powerful
Brooke g5 and again white was in the
driving seat it seemed check some
somehow somewhere around here maybe then
there must be or maybe one or two moves
to go I'm not sure there must be some
improvement I think it should be good
for white but in the game he got huge
counter play black yeah so those are
brilliancy people were saying this is
brilliant this check this delicate check
and then join back with a bishop he just
ruptured the whites position he's
unanchored the night by this f-free this
nasty pin online the night's not
anchored in anymore and there's also
Bishop a success could be used for
Bishop d7 and rook h6 huge fresh now
very nicely played yeah and
unfortunately he went for the win as you
say he went for the win with rookie six
instead of rook d6 so rook d6 would have
probably prompted rookie one there's so
much pressure here to deal with but now
it seems anand remarkably plays well
high-precision moves and Jack yeah and
everything is he played them quickly
awesome no he always kept his time
advantage yeah so maybe around here I
think maybe the biggest should be seven
move was much more something which I
appointed up m-maybe black hair could
have could have played better here to to
avoid all this unpleasant end game stuff
hmm okay but um yeah let's um let's go
body I think it was a draw for very long
time low pools getting swaps off check
white now emerging porn up um but now
that single port port had some promise
check
because it was free reign down bored in
theory yeah it was good enough to to get
rid of the pretender connected porn so
trying to reach maybe if earlier
theoretically drawn position yeah so and
I kept is cool here and check that okay
so he in this position he gave up a free
for that h4 Menace with rock age five so
he's still a pawn up but near
theoretically draw position but
unfortunately check a very nasty night
jack emerged which happens to people
when they're forced to play instantly
almost these nasty night folks one of
them just simplifies to a technically
one rook and pawn ending so this now
gets the transformation to a technically
one real component in here if King be a
truck g8 mating so what else can black
do unfortunately black slacks hope this
here is me in this position again it's
over it's hope because good this pool is
actually enough in this so not yet so is
everything set up for for the win here
because let's say for instance right
would have would have this look on on on
let's say a g5 yeah yeah then rook rook
fa just look a rogue f6 check is just
wrong oh yeah it's so coincidence oh
isn't it yeah it's it's everything set
up perfectly to win Oh unbelievable it's
a bit a bit unlucky it unlucky also yeah
unbelievable yeah so not all look
important things is drawing us another
saying he said that track some some
sights on someone said that once so even
doubt it was always tatic over he had so
many famous circled so
me in this in this case it might be
right even about what I'm not so good
with this who said what I know all this
but not quite sure who said said those
okay so you know we've reached the final
position Y and yet despite putting up a
huge fight here this black girl font had
to resign which is of course in this
short for mature for games a huge blow
so we need to to check to get back in
the next game most likely yeah okay i
hope i hope people on YouTube got
something from our extended commentary
here and we're starting to master the
annotation things that i think a little
bit so i hope you enjoyed it everyone
and will be uploading to are both our
channels comments or questions on both
our channels okay yeah thanks thanks
Chris thanks everyone for watching and
so much